so as we get into the Killing Joke I'm
actually really excited to bring you
guys this story and the reason why is
because The Killing Joke is considered
by all standards of measurement the
definitive Joker story this is what many
people look at and see as the one Joker
story above all which and I in my
opinion I think it's actually pretty
accurate The Killing Joke I think is a
story that is timeless people will look
at the Joker comics in 50 years and
they'll look back at The Killing Joke
and still say this is one of the
greatest stories ever told and I think
we can say that because the story was
written in the 1980s and the fact that
it stands the test of time I think is a
testament to how well this story was
done by Alan Moore but what we find as
we begin this story is that we meet up
with Batman and as he's traveling to
Arkham Asylum and Batman for whatever
reason seems to be meeting up or I guess
at the very least planning to meet with
the Joker and as he gets into the
building of course meets up with
Commissioner Gordon and he passes the
cells of a few people and ultimately
walks into cell 801 which is identified
as name unknown which of course is
correct because we don't really know the
actual origin behind the Joker because
DC hasn't really given it to us they
haven't really told us exactly what the
origin is but what happens as a Batman
enters the SL as he sees the Joker
appears to be playing solitaire and and
sits down across from him and what he
says is that he said we just come to
talk to the Joker and this is one of the
things that I thought was very
interesting reading this story because
it seemed very uncharacteristic of
Batman to let down his guard in a lot of
ways and try to relate to the Joker on a
personal level and what he says is that
he's been thinking about both the Joker
and himself for quite some time that if
they keep traveling down this road in
the end they're going to kill each other
that one of them is going to have to die
and so what he says is that he wants to
make sure that he's basically made a
genuine attempt here to try to reconcile
with the Joker to try to identify
directly with the Joker so that if that
circumstance arrives we're both the
Joker and Batman kill each other that
Batman won't be able to say that he
didn't do everything he
but he begins to get frustrated here and
this is where I think the story gets
really really interesting what happens
is in his frustration he physically
grabs the hand of the Joker and when he
does he sees that some white white
I guess makeup of some kind rubs off on
his hands and this immediately tells
Batman that this is not the Joker and so
what happens as Batman seizes the
individual and smears his hands across
his face and when he does he realizes
that this is somebody impersonating the
Joker and what's interesting here is
that as far as I know we don't know who
this person is
then this person may very well not have
known what he's done and in fact I don't
even think we're really given any origin
as to why this person had done what they
did but what he's done here is
effectively freed the Joker from
captivity and in fact Batman goes on to
say this Batman goes on to say that this
person has no idea what they've done
they've released an insanity that just
simply cannot be contained on the city
of Gotham now Batman is an initial
intention here I think as far as we can
tell is that maybe he wants to pummel
this person but of course Commissioner
Gordon steps in and says of the laws
that govern the treatment of patients
keep Batman from doing this and so of
course Batman lets him go and throws his
hair towards towards Commissioner Gordon
which is courses a response to
Commissioner Gordon's statement that
have Batman harms a hair on his head
then it'll cause all kinds of problems
for them and so what we do is we
transition to the actual Joker and the
real Joker is apparently investigating
some kind of fairgrounds looking through
some sort of maybe former amusement park
that has since become abandoned and
derelict and what he's doing is speaking
with the owner of this of this amusement
park and it's kind of funny here because
the owner is surprised that the Joker is
even remotely interested in this that
there are all kinds of things here that
could be that could injure people but of
course as we know the Joker would love
nothing more than to basically have an
amusement park that's a giant deathtrap
and so the Joker says that he loves it
that he's crazy for this kind of a thing
and so as the Joker and this individual
are continuing to discuss this person's
talking about how the Joker has the
potential of this person has a potential
to revitalize everything and what's
funny here is this man does not seem to
know that this is the Joker or the very
least maybe he doesn't know who the
Joker is or he thinks it's just some
person dressed up as a clown and of
course Joker being who he is is
feeding off of this and letting this man
continue this mindset what we do is we
actually jump back to what seems to be
the origin story of the Joker here and
what we're going to find with this
origin story and one of the things that
again I think is really really funny
about this is the Joker's going to both
give us his origin story and then retcon
it in the exact same at the exact same
time and what happens here is we meet up
with some man who's heading back home
and in speaking with his wife and what
he's saying is that he apparently had
auditioned for some kind of a of a role
as a comedian and the problem here was
that when the time came for him to
deliver the punchline that he choked and
so as a result they simply said they'll
just call him later on which of course
we know that to me that they're probably
not going to call him at all and so in a
state of feeling as though he's somehow
inadequate here he freaks out on his
wife Janine when when she simply says Oh
in response to his news and again this
is him just displaying his inadequacy
displaying his guilt over the fact that
he feels like he can't support his wife
or their there soon I guess their child
that'll be coming into the world
relatively soon the way he feels he
should be able to and so what happens is
that as they begin to reconcile that he
says that he hates this life that he
lives that he feels like he's a loser
here the reason being because he can't
provide for his family the way that he
needs to they're staying in the house of
a woman named on mrs. Berkus and that
what seems to be going on is that she
doesn't really seem to like him and
indeed again he thinks that the way she
looks at him is a reflection of how he
views himself in the sense that he has
his own self-loathing here and so what
he says is that all he wants here is
enough money to be able to set them up
to be able to get them into a good
neighborhood in a good part of town and
he says that women on the street can do
I can earn that much money without
really doing anything too in-depth so me
just what they do by going about and
engaging in illicit sexual activities
which of course draws a draws a laugh
from his wife and what his wife says is
that she still loves him no matter what
position their family is in whether it
is at their pour whether their well
for whether he has a job or not that her
affection for him remains the same and
so what we do is we pick back up with a
joker in the current time scape and
what's going on into this current
current moment is of course we see the
owner of this establishment of this AI
guess theme park riding one of the toy
elephants and they're joking around and
and he's having a good time and talking
about how some of these things are still
sturdy and that while some of the things
will need to be fixed up not everything
there's a total loss here and so what
the Joker says is that this man's silver
tongue as he refers to it has basically
sold the Joker on this place and so he
says they should shake hands but what
happens here and this is actually
something I expected to see when I had
read this story was that the Joker had
some kind of a needle strapped to his
hand and so when when the Joker and this
man shake hands
this man is basically injected with the
with the Joker's toxin which of course
is a homework part of the Joker's
history and we were is revealed to us
here that as the Joker begins to walk
away that this toxin has already taken
effect in a very short amount of time
and this man is effectively dead with a
very I guess disgusting grin on his face
and so what we do is we jump back to
Batman and Batman is simply looking
through looking through his cards or
looking at the Joker card and so on and
so again as he begins to go through
these various files what he says is I
guess what he realizes here is that he
doesn't really know where to start that
all information regarding the Joker is
really subject to whatever it is that
he's gained over the years but that no
one knows anything about him his
intendant's aren't known and no one
really has any idea what it is that he
may be doing or where it is he's going
to have to go and this is a struggle for
Batman and the reason why is because of
the Joker's insanity again no one knows
what his intentions are and so Bruce
wayne/batman is basically going to have
to wait until the Joker makes his move
before he before he's actually able to
engage in any kind of an action here and
so what we do is we jump to Commissioner
Gordon and Barbara Gordon and
Commissioner Gordon is of course making
different cutouts and adding to his his
existing collage of various items
belonging to Batman and Barbara Gordon
is commenting on this Farber Gordon
saying that it's time that he began to
put these things away that he takes some
time away that his job should be left at
work and that what he's at home he
should simply just enjoy being at peace
and being away from the
chaotic nature of what is job entails
and so what happens as we're talking is
that there's a knock at the door and
Barbara Gordon goes to answer it because
she says that this is supposed to be
Colleen a friend of hers from across the
street and that the two of them are
supposed to be going to a yoga class and
what happens when the door opens is that
we see the Joker who's actually wearing
a fabulous outfit of a Hawaiian shirt
and his purple hat and pulls a gun and
shoots Barbara Gordon and this was huge
because this was the Joker's first real
strike add somebody close to Bruce Wayne
this was his first real strike as
someone who really settled with Bruce
Wayne who was really a major part of the
internal Batman family and as we'll find
out later on in this story this this
bullet to Barbara Gordon will actually
result in her paralysis and so what
happens here is that Commissioner Gordon
of course reacts the exact way that you
think he would he begins to freak out he
begins to panic
then of course he tries to go after the
Joker but the Joker has a couple of his
henchmen begin to pummel Commissioner
Gordon and then seize Commissioner
Gordon and again what we see is the
Joker giving us some narrative here he's
basically I guess relating Barbara
Gordon to a book or to a to a library
saying that he doesn't really care much
for this volume and this may very well
be the fact that Joker's referring I
guess if you can cipher through it
referring to this newest incarnation and
maybe Batman's sidekick that the Joker
had always seen himself I guess as a
person as far as we can tell who appears
to be under the guise of trying to make
the Batman stronger by killing off
people that mean a lot to him and
basically going through this Forge of
fire that would strengthen him as an
individual but again it's really
difficult to cipher through the Joker's
jargon the Joker's nonsense and get
through his insanity to get to the heart
of the matter in truth
much like the Joker's history what it is
that he means whenever he says something
is really just up for scrutiny it's
really just up for debate here and so
again we see him up poking fun at
Barbara Gordon as Jim Gordon is taken
away unconscious and it seems as though
he begins undressing her although we
don't really know what his motive is at
this point in time and so what we do is
we begin to wrap up this first half of
the video is that we pick up with the
Joker as he is a meeting with a couple
individuals at a bar and
happening here is that these individuals
I guess are enlisting the aid of Joker
there and listing the help of Joker and
the whole reason for this is because as
the Joker says I guess he's really going
to be involving himself in a crime of
sorts he's really going to be
participating in some sort of a violent
act and the reason being because what
this will do is it will give him the
money he needs in order to earn were to
give both him and his wife Janine a
better life in order to give them a
better role and given the kind of life
that he believes he should be able to
provide as a man and so what happens is
that the criminals tell him that he's
going to be dressed in a disguise so
that no one knows who he is that what
they're going to be doing is they're
basically going to be giving him the
hood of the Red Hood now this is a
really really interesting thing here
because what this tells us is that the
Joker may well be being set up here they
might be duping him here and they might
be tricking him here but again any of
the uncertainty that the Joker has is
ass waged by the promises these two men
make of the amount of money they're
going to get that the Joker is going to
be put in a situation basically where no
one's going to know who he is you can
look around by using some sort of
two-way a two-way glasses built into the
hood but the Joker's identity is going
to remain anonymous and so the only
reason he's here is to basically give
them a way to access the chemical plant
he had previously worked at so they can
carry out their plan and so the Joker
seems to see things on the up-and-up
perhaps maybe he sees things in a better
way but the idea here is that ultimately
any misgivings he has about engaging in
a life of crime are thrown away at the
future he could possibly have with its
wife and so what happens as things begin
to come to an end here is that we
ultimately see that the Joker begins to
to have some concerns here begins to
have some worries but ultimately what he
says is that after this that nothing is
ever going to be the same again with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly